streit um nord stream zwei eskaliert der
us-präsident verhängt sanktionen wegen
der ostseepipeline die bundesregierung
spricht von einmischung in innere
angelegenheiten volle fußgängerzonen
beim weihnachtsshopping am letzten
adventswochenende sind viele noch auf
der suche nach dem passenden last minute
geschenk und jubel bei den nordischen
kombinierern im schneegestöber von
ramsau holt vinzenz geiger den ersten
deutschen saisonsieg
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara höll wie guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch rudi cerne für den sport hallo
guten note 2 soll russisches gas nach
deutschland befördern den amerikanern
ist die ostseepipeline schon immer ein
dorn im auge sie werfen europa vor sich
von russischem gas abhängig zu machen
jetzt hat us präsident james sanktionen
verhängt um den bau kurz vor der
fertigstellung zu stoppen dazu gleich
mehr
zunächst jan fischer mit einem kurzen
überblick über das milliarden projekt
nord stream 2 verläuft von russland nach
lubmin
die gesamtlänge rund 1200 kilometer
parallel zur pipeline nord stream 1
jährlich können durch nur 22 55
milliarden kubikmeter erdgas nach
deutschland und von dort nach europa
strömen hinter dem projekt steht der
teilstaatliche russische konzern gazprom
der die hälfte der kosten in höhe von
9,5 milliarden euro trägt die andere
hälfte stemmen fünf westeuropäische
unternehmen darunter die deutschen
juniper und wintershall der bisher wuchs
die pipeline jeden tag um drei kilometer
mehr als 1000 sind schon verlegt es
fehlt nur noch ein stück um die dänische
insel bornholm
die schweizer firma ots die mit
spezialschiffen die rohre durch die
ostsee verlegt hat direkt auf die
amerikanischen sanktionen reagiert und
die arbeit vorerst ausgesetzt ihren
managern drohen einreiseverbote auch das
vermögen des unternehmens in den usa
könnte eingefroren werden wenn sie
weitermachen finanzminister scholz nennt
die sanktionen einen schweren eingriff
in die inneren angelegenheiten
deutschlands und europas aus berlin
cornelia schiemenz es war heute nacht
eine 30 deutscher zeit als donald trump
ernst machte auf der luftwaffenbasis
andrews bei washington unterschrieb er
das sanktions gesetz gegen nord stream 2
damit werden firmen die beim bau der
ostsee pipeline beteiligt sind
sanktioniert die bundesregierung
bedauert dass in der ard lehnt
vizekanzler olaf scholz gegenmaßnahmen
aber vorerst ab es ist jetzt erst mal
sache des unternehmens
und der unternehmen die an dem bau
beteiligt sind die nächsten
entscheidungen zu treffen für uns ist
klar dass wir das nicht akzeptieren
werden dass eine solche sanktion
verhängt wird und der amerikanischen
regierung das auch in allen gesprächen
und bei allen gelegenheiten deutlich
machen werden
die amerikaner lehnen die ostseepipeline
seit jahren ab wohl auch aus
wirtschaftlichen interessen weil sie
gern ihr eigenes flüssiggas auf dem
europäischen markt verkaufen wollen
das offizielle argument deutschland und
europa begeben sich in abhängigkeit von
russland damit würden
sicherheitsinteressen der usa verletzt
diese sanktionen sind eine weitere
edition für eine belastung des
transatlantischen verhältnisses sie sind
nicht gut
aber schauen sie noch einmal sie kommen
ja nicht überraschend man konnte sich
darauf einstellen nicht nur die
amerikaner auch mehrheitlich die
osteuropäischen länder hadern mit der
pipeline die grünen verurteilen das
ganze projekt nord stream ist ein
projekt das ökonomisch keinen sinn hat
für deutschland das ökologisch
kontraproduktiv ist und dass europa
spaltet diese pipeline ist unnötig und
sie ist schädlich das heißt wir brauchen
sie nicht
nord stream 2 wird wohl trotzdem weiter
gebaut allerdings mit verzögerungen
dafür begann in moskau wackelt jetzt das
ganze pipeline projekt also alle
politiker die sich heute zu diesem thema
zu wort gemeldet haben haben
unterstrichen und betont dass nord
stream 2 auf jeden fall fertig gebaut
wird
das russische außenministerium zum
beispiel hat in seinem statement gesagt
oder besser gesagt geschrieben dass man
es hier in russland ja schon gewohnt sei
dass die wirtschaftsentwicklung gehemmt
werden solle durch sanktionen und dass
man hier in russland eben auch gelernt
habe mittlerweile damit umzugehen
auch das betreiberkonsortium selbst sagt
dass der bau so schnell wie möglich
fortgesetzt werden soll
man wird es sicherlich sich auf die
suche machen nach neuen verlegeschiffe
es fehlen ja noch ungefähr 300 kilometer
pipeline und klar ist schon auch dass
die fertigstellung der pipeline sich
jetzt verzögern wird
wie reagiert russland
präsident putin hatte in seiner
jährlichen pressekonferenz am donnerstag
schon gesagt also bevor die sanktionen
unterschrieben waren dass er das für
einen unfreundlichen akt hält und dass
russland mit einer spiegel genauen
antwort darauf reagieren werde
wie genau diese antwort jetzt ausfallen
wird dazu gibt es heute noch keine
nachrichten
die letzten tage waren hier eigentlich
davon geprägt zumindest in sachen gas
von einer einigung zwischen der ukraine
und russland quasi auf den letzten
drücker hat man sich da einigen können
auf transit von russischem gas durch die
ukraine
und beide seiten haben diesen vertrag
eigentlich als erfolg gewertet
und im moment gibt es unter den neuen
vorzeichen noch keine anhaltspunkte
dafür dass zb an diesem vertrag jetzt
gerüttelt werden soll
vielen dank für diese einschätzung aus
moskau für bekam sollen auch im
kommenden jahr internationale hilfsgüter
an millionen notleidende in syrien
geliefert werden
das diskutieren gerade die vereinten
nationen eine unter anderem von
deutschland ausgearbeitete resolution
sei hilfslieferungen für weitere zwölf
monate vor wurde aber von russland und
china abgelehnt
das argument russlands die humanitäre
lage in syrien habe sich deutlich
verbessert seit 2014 liefern die un
hilfsgüter nach syrien
das mandat dafür läuft am 10 januar aus
in europa ist die afrikanische
schweinepest auf dem vormarsch eine
führt ihre tödliche seuche vor allem in
polen rückt sie immer näher an die
deutsche grenze heran
zäune sollen jetzt verhindern dass
infizierte tiere das virus einschleppen
dänemark hat bereits welche an der
grenze zu deutschland errichtet als
erstes bundesland baut jetzt auch
brandenburg schutzzäune entlang der
deutsch-polnischen grenze zwischen
frankfurt an der oder und sachsen in
google stehen die ersten schulen jan
meyer
meter für meter stellen ihm
forstarbeiter am ufer der neiße auf bis
weihnachten sollen über 100 kilometer
schutzzaun stehen
die erwartung ist dass stromschläge die
wildschweine aus polen abschrecken so
soll verhindert werden dass die
afrikanische schweinepest deutschland
wir hoffen natürlich dass wir den
übertritt verhindern können und würden
uns natürlich auch wünschen dass die
polnischen kollegen die solche in ihrem
land eindämmen können im moment sprechen
die daten aber dafür dass das
infektionsgeschehen noch ansteigen des
schweinebauer hans-christian daniels
rechnet mit dem schlimmsten
in seinen ställen leben 11.000 tiere so
schnell haben wir alle nicht damit
gerechnet dass das so dicht an land
brandenburg kommt und die maßnahmen
müssen eben deutlicher werden einen
neuen zaun hat er schon errichtet
außerdem soll eine desinfektions matte
verhindern dass mitarbeiter an ihren
schuhen den erreger in die ställe tragen
der zaun an der grenze bietet keinen
hundertprozentigen schutz denn die
krankheit die für schweine fast immer
tödlich endet wurde bisher vor allem
durch menschen verbreitet dass man
dringend unbedingt nochmal appellieren
sollte dass menschen die wirklich aus
regieren kommen wo ausbrüche
festgestellt worden sind tierische
lebensmittel nicht mitbringen nach
deutschland und schon gar nicht in
irgendeiner form hier entsorgen das in
den kreislauf kommen können und
wildschweine daran kommen können für
menschen ist das virus ungefährlich für
alle förster und waldspaziergänger ist
nun besondere wachsamkeit geboten wer
ein totes wildschwein findet kann das
über die app tier iv und kataster melden
oder direkt das veterinäramt anrufen
so langsam beginnt die wintersaison in
den bergen und in österreich heißt das
auch es gelten wieder fahrverbote damit
die urlauber auf der autobahn bleiben
und nicht auf nebenstrecken ausweichen
und die ortsdurchfahrten verstopfen
wie es heute war zeigen alexander pohl
und thomas john j
die a8 nahe rosenheim hier strömt nur
der regen stillstand gen süden abfahren
ausweichen auf landstraßen in österreich
keine gute idee denn hier dürfen nur
anlieger durch für alle anderen heißt es
also umdrehen zurück in die schlange
solche sperren sie gelten tagsüber bis
ostermontag etwa auf strecken um
innsbruck und kufstein
unser ziel ist mit diesen maßnahmen
dafür zu sorgen dass die ganzen
ortschaften die vom hauptreiseverkehr
betroffen sind das die nicht komplett
verstopft sind und dass wir hier die
verkehrssicherheit aufrecht erhalten
können
besseres atmen besseres durchkommen für
rettungswagen deswegen gab es schon im
sommer durch fahrverbote
heute gab es wenig probleme und viel
verständnis schnell nach hause kämen
versteht man aber natürlich die probleme
auf der autobahn sitzen wo man
eigentlich nicht nach hause kennt sagt
übrigens auch der adac
denn staus auf fernstraßen lösen sich
oft schneller auf als auf dem land gute
nachricht übrigens auf 5
autobahnabschnitten an der grenze ist
die maut abgeschafft zumindest bei den
gebühren gilt also dort freie fahrt wir
schauen in den nahen osten nach israel
unsere korrespondentin nicola albrecht
ist durchs heilige land gereist sie
zeigt unter anderem was der
dauerkonflikt zwischen israelis und
palästinensern für die menschen dort
bedeutet ihre route ging von der
libanesischen grenze bis hin zum guten
mehr im jordantal erlebte sie beide
seiten
wir sind auf der roten ein t unterwegs
der lebensader des heiligen landes
treffen menschen die ihre heimat lieben
mit der politik hadern und um ihr dasein
kämpfen so wie hier im jordantal wo
illegal siedeln die israelis und
palästinenser auf sichtweite leben unter
denen die israelische regierung ihre
pläne vorgelegt hat das gebiet
annektieren ist die lage noch
angespannter erzählt uns rallye tube die
israelische besatzung und die siedler
rundherum machen es uns nicht leicht die
beide plätze sind eingeschränkt wir
haben nicht mehr die freiheit die weite
des tals zu nass wenn ich in die nähe
der siedler dort hinten kommen dann
bekomme ich ärger khalid ist beduine
seine familie lebt seit jahrzehnten in
dieser ecke des von israel besetzten
jordan teils während unserer
dreharbeiten wirkt eher eingeschüchtert
unsere kamera sei in den augen der
israelischen siedler auf dem hügel
sicher eine provokation erklärt er uns
wir fahren ohne khalid den hügel hoch
wollen die siedler treffen ihre meinung
hören doch sie wollen unsere fragen
nicht beantworten
ein paar kilometer entfernt haben wir
mehr glück sie sind davon überzeugt dass
die palästinenser endlich weichen müssen
ist das nicht denn das ist unser land
unser ort die araber kommen auch hierher
für sicherheit sorgen die soldaten hier
in der nähe
sie passen auf uns aus hinter ruf des
heiligen landes so nennen die menschen
hier das gebiet eine annexion wäre ein
bruch des völkerrechts doch im großen
konfliktfeld jeder quadratmeter
auch im hinterhof zwischen shalom und
salam die reportage von nicola albrecht
können sie am montag sehen um 19 uhr 25
oder schon jetzt in der zdf mediathek
das weihnachtsgeschenk kann im besten
fall pures glück auslösen aber eben auch
abgrundtiefe enttäuschung und familien
krisen unterm baum hoch komplizierte
sache also wer heute noch gestresst
durch die stadt hetzt hat vielleicht zu
lange auf den geistesblitz für die
absolut ultimative geschenk idee gehofft
jetzt werden fakten
schaffen entsprechend voll war es in den
fußgängerzonen aus hamburg sven rieten
zum fototermin mit dem weihnachtsmann
ins kaufhaus so viel tradition muss sein
beim einkaufen aber hört die liebe zum
lagen auf jeder vierte deutsche wird in
diesem jahr schon online geschenke
kaufen
daran kann auch das himmlische wetter in
der vollen hamburger innenstadt heute
nichts ändern werde dann im internet 20
euro sparen kann wir sind ja alle nicht
reicht das ist ja nun mal so den coffee
um enten dazu bereit wie mir das tut sie
waren auch online aber es ist halt
unpersönlichen man kann das nicht
anfassen man sieht das nicht man sieht
die qualität nicht und es macht auch
spaß einzukaufen
der trend geht allerdings dahin dass es
immer mehr online werden ist leider so
im durchschnitt gibt jeder deutsche in
diesem jahr 400 euro für
weihnachtsgeschenke aus regional gibt es
unterschiede so planen die düsseldorfer
mit 639 euro
die münchner nur mit 209 euro gegenüber
dem vorjahr sind das 37 prozent weniger
offensichtlich sitzt das geld nicht mehr
so locker
shopping als freizeitaktivität hat immer
wieder an weiter an bedeutung verloren
das heißt man wartet vielleicht noch mit
seinen ausgaben so lange wie es geht
unter blies der handel nochmal kräftig
ins horn die letzten unentschlossenen
fehlen noch in der diesjährigen
weihnachts bilanz die last minute
geschenke jedenfalls sind angerichtet
beauty ist so eigentlich der bereich wo
jeder hin strömen wenn es noch um last
minute geht das ist der klassiker
angefangen von parfums über vielleicht
auch eine abgestimmte pflege oder
dekorative kosmetik da greifen alle gern
noch mal auch zuletzt am rande der
weihnachtsparade stehen dann online und
klassische shopper seite an seite
danach aber gehen die einen nach hause
und die anderen stürzen sich zurück in
den einkaufstrubel eine art vorgezogenes
weihnachtsgeschenk gab es heute schon
für die leipziger fußball fans ja
richtig hatte arbeitet vom klub rb
leipzig ist höchstwahrscheinlich
herbstmeister der fußball-bundesliga
erstmals seit 2009 geht damit der
inoffizielle titel nicht an bayern
münchen oder borussia dortmund die
samstags ergebnisse vom 17 spieltag
rb leipzig schlägt augsburg mit 3 zu 1
bayern mit zwei späten toren gegen
wolfsburg schalke freiburg 2 2 1
unterliegt leverkusen 0 zu 1
im keller duell gewinnt köln gegen
bremen eins zu null
ausführlich im sportstudio härter gegen
gladbach gestern hoffenheim dortmund
zwei zu eins bleibt sich aufgrund der
deutlich besseren tordifferenz von
gladbach kaum noch aufzuholen
unverändert dahinter bayern dortmund und
schalke die zweite hälfte beginnt mit
augsburg in der unteren hälfte spielen
noch fünf mannschaften paderborn
tabellenletzter mehr zum fußball dann im
aktuellen sportstudio ab 23 uhr 30 zu
gast kurz vor der em
handball-nationaltorhüter andreas wolf
vinzens geiger hat den deutschen
nordischen kombinierern den ersten
weltcup sieg der saison beschert in
ramsau am dachstein setzte sich der
22-jährige im zielsprint gegen den
norweger jahren magnus rieber durch der
die ersten fünf saisonrennen gewonnen
hatte
[Musik]
geschafft der scheinbar unbesiegbare ist
geschlagen vinzenz geiger legt mit einem
souveränen 90 meter sprung den
grundstein für seinen erfolg platz zehn
und damit 34 sekunden rückstand auf den
norwegischen weltcup führenden jannis
lieber eine gute ausgangsposition für
den starken deutschen läufer taktisch
klug übernimmt vinzens geiger bereits in
der vorletzten runde die führung und
gibt diese nicht mehr ab der norweger
jan mannes rieber wird zweiter und ist
erstmals in dieser saison besiegt ja
waren brutal hartes rennen aber ja ich
denke es war einfach genial
erfreulich auch fabian ruine wird
dritter eric frenzel belegt platz vier
und auch die skispringer freuen sich
über einen podestplatz beim sieg des
polen kamil stoch in engelberg fliegt
der oberstdorfer karl geiger auf rang
drei
die faust von karl geiger nach dem
nächsten top resultat der skisprung
saison 133,5 meter im ersten durchgang
135 im zweiten springen in oberstdorf
auf den dritten platz
besser der zweitplatzierte österreicher
stefan kraft und tagessieger kam es doch
aus polen aber auch geiger springt damit
in die favoritenrolle für die
vierschanzentournee
ich lehne sie mal nicht ab ich bin ich
bin stolz darauf dass ich da auch in
fabriken presse zu gehör
trotzdem muss man einfach sehen wie sich
nach tagen und dann kann sie noch alles
drehen
zum beispiel morgen beim nächsten und
letzten springen vor der tournee ja
morgen machen wir weiter mit wintersport
zweiter teil 10 15 geht es los
wir haben zum schluss noch ein bisschen
weihnachtsbeleuchtung in magdeburg ist
die sogar historisch rund 60
verschiedene skulpturen zeichnen die
geschichte der stadt nach wie zb ein
experiment aus dem 17 jahrhundert zur
kraft des vakuums damals versuchten
pferde vergeblich zwei luft leer
gepumpte halbkugeln auseinanderzureißen
noch bis anfang februar ist die lichter
welt zu bestaunen
morgen ist winter anfangen ob das wetter
das beherzigt erzählt gleich erste
verlieh claus kleber begrüßt sie um
viertel nach elf im heute-journal und
wir sagen tschüss bedanken uns für ihr
interesse und wünschen noch einen
unbeschwerten samstagabend bis morgen
wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
einführung grüner ampel und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter morgens
winteranfang 519 geht es los aber das
wetter möchte davon nichts wissen
es kommt regen aus dem westen wieder
einmal muss man sagen und er erreichte
uns etwa bis zur mitte
in den bergen da gibt es durchaus schnee
aber nicht im flachland schauen wir in
die nacht und da wird es im westen schon
ziemlich bewölkt sein und regnen und
auch nach süden hin
in den östlichen landesteilen und auch
im südosten bildet sich nebel oder
teilweise klar ist sogar auf
temperaturen sinken dabei auf null grad
an der neiße und an den alpen und 7 grad
ganz im westen deutschlands morgen im
tagesverlauf vor allem im westen viele
wolken und auch im süden und dazu regnet
es im süden teilweise kräftiger wenn
wind aus südwestlichen richtungen
im osten deutschlands kann mal die sonne
raus blinzeln aber insgesamt ist es
ziemlich bewölkt bei temperaturen von
fünf grad im nordosten deutschlands und
10 grad zum beispiel ganz im westen die
nächsten tage es wird durchwachsen
weitergehen mit regen 4 bis 10 grad in
den mittelgebirgen kann es mal zu
schneeflocken kommen so sieht es dann
auch am heiligabend und am ersten
feiertag aus ein schöner abend